you progr you Milly ate me he left your
mark on me buddy thing work you put my
mind time I'll kill you until this
moment you have not known suffering
all right another your mouth bruise so
now I'm gonna kill you for all these
orcs to say oh I said you were an
optimist now what that is might it's
about sizing up a situation that's
bloody impossible and saying here on
I'll have a go I'm exactly the same way
I like him rules
kill the boss come on in shadow of
Mordor we introduced a way to create
unique personal stories for every player
and in shadow of war we're expanding the
Nemesis system to new features we're
really excited about our forging an army
of followers and nemesis fortresses here
we'll use the Ring of Power and recruit
this Olaf Brewster chopper to expand our
army then we're going to assault a
fortress controlled by one of our odds
over lovers
oh that was nasty
boy break the yolk itis qma that little
swords good for a tickle maybe were you
gonna need more than that too tight may
down noise one Ranger
this never happened to me before
Bry Lord our Lord same thing really
it results me ripping spines out which I
like to do anyway so either ways a win a
fine addition to our man nice burst from
your honor I will be your shadow no one
gets to you without my say-so
don't worry about my enemies they will
all follow eventually you want to apply
your flag in Mordor you'll need to do a
deep there's a fortress near boy ISAT
ruled by a two-headed troll big as a
mountain deadly smart witch
Marcus he'd have to be given the two
heads you takin down he'll send a
message to Sauron anchor yourself some
nice new digs as part of the bargain I'm
not going to do this alone gather your
troops will do up just make sure you let
me Poppy's heads off won't ya
[Music]
so we already have a few loyal followers
in our army and recruiting booth means
we're ready to assault the fortress and
overthrow the overlord we're enormous ly
expanding the open-world of Mordor to
new regions like Sarah Gaston Tirith
angle morose a massive living breathing
world filled with orc society tribes and
wildlife as well as stories and secrets
you crave mean to any other or would
have died but I survived more than that
I thrived my brothers put me back
together stronger than ever but they
didn't make me into what I am you jeet
you created the machine No
final machine he's trying to get across
born or seeking vengeance he's one of
the seven-year-old crying daddy
she was cool
you disorder the steel
instead of killing the machine will
dominate in mind we can take advantage
of his abilities during the fortress
assaults you took out the old rule
before we charge headfirst into battle
we should plan our attack and select our
followers
[Applause]
he'll lose Rocco doggies
sighs Erica
mudlick speech is a little rusty action
on arcing wood which is a pine in the
ass back to hazard a case he said you're
all gonna die horribly yeah mark on a
black well I will handle the overlord
you focus on the defenders to fine focus
[Applause]
there are unlimited ways to forge your
story in conquer Mordor in shadow of war
and we can't wait to show you more this
week at e3 thank you very much
exclusive world premiere